♪ ♪
>> A FEDERAL JUDGE WHO YOU
APPOINTED HAS JUST RULED THAT
YOU MUST GIVE CNN REPORTER JOHN
ACOSTA HIS PRESS PASS BACK.
YOUR REACTION TO THE RULING?
>> IT'S FINE.
IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL.
WHAT THEY SAID THOUGH IS THAT WE
HAVE TO CREATE RULES AND
REGULATIONS FOR CONDUCT, ET
CETERA. WE'RE DOING THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO WRITE IT UP RIGHT
NOW.
IT IS NOT A BIG DEAL.
IF HE MISBEHAVES, WE'LL THROW
HIM OUT OR STOP THE NEWS
CONFERENCE.
IF I THINK SOMEBODY'S ACTING OUT
OF SORTS, I WILL LEAVE.
I'LL SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
EVERYBODY.
I APPRECIATE YOU COMING.
AND I'LL LEAVE.
AND THOSE REPORTERS WILL NOT BE
TOO FRIENDLY TO WHOEVER IT IS
THAT'S ACTING UP.
>> THAT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP
DURING AN INTERVIEW THAT WILL
AIR IN FULL ON FOX NEWS SUNDAY
WITH CHRIS WALLACE.
CNN REPORTER ACOSTA HAS REGAINED
ACCESS TO THE WHITE HOUSE, BUT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS EXPECTED
TO ADDRESS REPORTER CONDUCT WITH
NEW REGULATIONS.
JOINING US NOW IS SARAH SANDERS.
SO ONE OF THE STATEMENTS THAT
CAME OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY WAS A STATEMENT FROM YOU
THAT INDICATED THAT THERE WERE
RULES BEING DEVELOPED AND A
PROTOCOL BEING DEVELOPED.
WHEN WILL WE EXPECT TO SEE WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE?
>> WELL, I THINK THE BIGGEST
THING TO TAKE AWAY IS -- AND THE
PLACE THAT WE FOCUSED ON IS
EXACTLY WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID.
WE SUPPORT A FREE PRESS, BUT
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS DOESN'T
MEAN FREEDOM TO BE DISRUPTIVE,
RUDE, INTERCEPT, AND IMPEDE THE
ABILITY OF THE COLLEAGUES FROM
ACTUALLY BEING ABLE TO DO THEIR
JOBS, AS WELL AS WHITE HOUSE
STAFF BEING ABLE TO DO THEIRS.
WE'VE LAID OUT IN A LETTER TO
CNN AND THEIR TEAM WHAT WE THINK
WERE SOME OF THE MISSTEPS THAT
THEIR REPORTER MADE AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE ON NOVEMBER 7TH IN A
LETTER THAT WE SENT THEM
TONIGHT.
AND WE EXPECT TO SEE A RESPONSE
FROM THAT.
THE JUDGE I THINK WAS ACTUALLY
VERY CLEAR THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS THE ABILITY TO SAY, YOU
CAN'T COME IN.
YOU DON'T HAVE -- FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS DOESN'T MEAN FREEDOM INTO
THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND HE SAID THERE HAS TO BE DUE
PROCESS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS FROM
THERE.
>> IT WAS A FIFTH AMENDMENT
RULING.
HE NEVER SAID THAT CNN HAD BEEN
DENIED THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THEY
CAN SAY WHATEVER THEY WANT.
THE GOVERNMENT, INCLUDING THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS NEVER SAID,
HERE'S WHAT YOU CAN'T SAY.
>> THEY ALSO HAVE 50-PLUS
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE THAT ARE HARD
PASS OLDERS AT CNN.
THEY ACTUALLY ARE ONE OF THE
INDIVIDUAL OUTLETS THAT HAS THE
MOST HARD PASSES OF ANY NEWS
OUTLET IN THE COUNTRY IS CNN.
THEY'RE ONE OF THE TOP THREE.
SO THE IDEA THAT THEY AREN'T
ABLE TO GET INFORMATION THEY
NEED FROM THE WHITE HOUSE IS
FRANEDLY LAUGHABLE.
>> HOW MANY SEATS ARE IN THAT
TRESS  PRESS ROOM?
>> 49 SEATS.
>> WHO GETS TO DECIDE WHOSE REAR
ENDS OCCUPY 49 SEATS AND HOW
COME THEY GET THEM AND THOUSANDS
OF OTHERS NEVER DO?
>> WE WORK WITH THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS ASSOCIATION.
THEY ARE THE PRIMARY PEOPLE WHO
HELP DETERMINE WHO THOSE SEATS
BELONG TO.
>> DO THEY GET TO PICK THEM OR
CAN YOU SAY, OKAY, ON THIS NEXT
THURSDAY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
JOURNALISTS FROM ANYWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY EXCEPT WASHINGTON.
>> THE ASSOCIATION DETERMINES
WHO SITS IN THAT ROOM.
>> THAT'S TRADITION.
IT'S NOT LAW.
? TRUE.
>> AND SO IF THERE WAS A DESIRE
TO GIVE OTHER JOURNALISTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT, BECAUSE I
THINK SOME PEOPLE SEE THESE SAME
FOLKS IN THERE EVERY DAY AND
THEY SAY, HOW COME THEY GET TO
DO IT?
I'M SURE THERE'S BROADCASTERS
WHO WOULD LOVE TO ASK THE
PRESIDENT QUESTIONS.
>> I THINK THAT'S CERTAINLY AN
OPTION TO EXPLORE AND MAYBE WE
WILL IN THIS WHITE HOUSE.
I KNOW THE PRESIDENT IS ONE OF
THE MOST ACCESSIBLE PRESIDENTS
PROBABLY EVER BUT CERTAINLY IN
MODERN HISTORY.
HE'S TAKEN IN THE LAST SIX WEEKS
LEADING UP TO THE MIDTERMS HE
TOOK 300 TIMES THE NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS FROM REPORTERS THAN
EITHER OF HIS PREDECESSORS.
THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS TO PRETEND HE
DOESN'T SUPPORT THE PRESS.
HE'S SOMEBODY WHO LOVES TO
ENGAGE WITH THE PRESS.
>> WE'VE NOTICED THAT.
WE HAVE.
>> AND THAT'S BECAUSE HE LOVES
TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK DIRECTLY TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE NEVER WANT TO PROHIBIT THAT
FROM TAKING PLACE, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, THOSE INDIVIDUALS
CAN'T BE DISRUPTIVE.
THEY CAN'T IMPEDE THE ABILITY OF
ANY INDIVIDUAL TO DO THEIR JOBS.
>> SO WHEN MIGHT WE SEE THE
RULES OR THE REQUIREMENTS, THE
PROTOCOL?
YOU'VE SAID YOU SENT THE LETTER
TO CNN TONIGHT.
IS THAT GOING TO BE IN A FEW
DAYS, FEW WEEKS?
>> WE'LL WORK WITH OUR TEAM ON
THAT AND CERTAINLY MOVING INTO
THANKSGIVING HOLIDAY WE'LL SEE
HOW LONG THAT PROCESS TAKES, BUT
I THINK THERE ARE SOME JUST
STANDARD PRACTICES.
LOOK, I THINK THE VERY BASIC
MINIMUM IS THAT IF CERTAIN
REPORTERS LIKE JIM ACOSTA CAN'T
BE ADULTS, THEN CNN NEEDS TO
SEND SOMEBODY IN THERE WHO CAN
BE.
>> IF HE ASKED THREE QUESTIONS
WHEN HE WAS ONLY SUPPOSED TO ASK
ONE, DOES THAT MAKE THE
REPORTERS TICKED OFF?
>> I'LL LEAVE THAT TO THEM.
BUT CERTAINLY PRIVATELY A NUMBER
OF THEM HAVE EXPRESSED THEIR
DISPLEASURE WITH THE FACT OF HIS
GRANDSTANDING AND THE POSITION
THAT HE OFTEN PUTS A LOT OF THEM
IN.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT SOMETHING
THEY WANT TO CELEBRATE NOR
DEFEND.
>> LET'S MOVE TO TOMORROW.
YOU'LL BE LOOKING AT HORRIFIC
SCENES, WORST FIRES IN THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
63 KNOWN DEAD, 600 UNACCOUNTED
FOR.
WHAT WILL THE PRESIDENT HOPE TO
SAY TOMORROW?
>> I THINK THE SIMPLEST MESSAGE
IS THAT WE'RE HERE.
WE'RE THERE FOR YOU.
WE WILL DO ANY AND EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO PROVIDE FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE AND FEDERAL
RESOURCES.
HE CONVEYED THAT I KNOW IN A
CALL TO GOVERNOR BROWN EARLIER
THIS WEEK.
HE'LL BE JOINING US WHEN WE GET
TO CALIFORNIA TOMORROW.
I THINK THIS WILL ACTUALLY
PROBABLY BE ONE OF THE HARDER
DAYS THAT WE'VE HAD IN THE TWO
YEARS OF THIS ADMINISTRATION,
NOT ONLY VISITING WITH THE
HORRIFIC AND SEEING THE SCENES
OF THE HORRIFIC WILDFIRES THAT
HAVE RAVAGED CALIFORNIA, BUT
ALSO TALKING WITH SOME OF THE
PEOPLE AND THE FAMILIES THAT
WERE IMPACTED BY THE SHOOTING
THERE NOT TOO LONG AGO.
IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY
DIFFICULT AND EMOTIONAL DAY, AND
I THINK THE BIGGEST TAKEAWAY
WILL BE THE PRESIDENT SAYING,
WE'RE HERE.
AND THANFULLY THE PRESIDENT'S
GOT BIG SHOULDERS AND I THINK
HE'S GOING TO GO THERE TO OFFER
THEM UP TO PEOPLE THAT NEED
THEM.
>> WE'VE ONLY GOT A MINUTE AND A
HALF LEFT, BUT I WANT TO COVER
THIS BECAUSE I DIDN'T SEE A LOT
IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
YOU HAD PEOPLE THAT REALLY
RANGED THE FULL SPECTRUM.
I WAS INVOLVED IN THIS.
ONE OF THE COMMITTEES TO HELP
TRAP SOME OF THE POLICY BASED ON
MY OWN EXPERIENCES.
THIS WAS HUGE.
THIS WAS MAJOR.
GIVE ME A SYNOPSIS OF WHAT THIS
LEGISLATION DOES THAT THE
PRESIDENT PUSHED THIS WEEK.
>> WELL, I THINK ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THINGS IS IT BRINGS THE
COUNTRY TOGETHER.
IT'S A BIPARTISAN, AND AREA
WHERE REPUBLICANS, DEMOCRATS,
EVERYONE CAN COME TOGETHER AND
AGREE THAT THIS IS A GOOD THING
TO SHOW A LITTLE GRACE AND A
LITTLE MERCY IN OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
SOMETHING THAT HASN'T BEEN DONE
IN A LONG TIME.
WE'VE HAD DECADES' WORTH OF BAD
DECISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPROPERLY PLACED PEOPLE AND
REALLY I THINK LONGER SENTENCES
THAN THEY DESERVED, NOT ALLOWED
PEOPLE TO HAVE A LIFE AFTER
PRISON.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE PRESIDENT,
VERY IMPORTANT TO JARED KUSHNER,
WHO'S DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB IN
HELPING DEVELOP AND REALLY WORK
THIS.
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED OVERNIGHT.
I THINK YOU SAW A LITTLE BIT OF
THE CULMINATION OF THAT.
>> HE SHOULD GET THE CREDIT FOR
THAT AND I HOPE HE WILL.
30 SECONDS AND THAT'S ALL WE'VE
GOT.
EARLIER TAMMY BRUCE SAID SARAH
SANDERS IS GOING TO BE LEAVING
THE WHITE HOUSE.
IS THERE SOMETHING YOU NEED TO
TELL YOUR DAD?
>> I HOPE NOT, NOT THAT I'M
AWARE OF, NO.
>> AND I TOLD HER, I SAID, WELL,
GEE, MAYBE YOU KNOW SOMETHING I
DON'T KNOW.
>> I THINK IT IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST PRIVILEGES AND
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITIES OF MY LIFE TO
SERVE IN THIS ADMINISTRATION, TO
WORK WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THE SUCCESSES THAT HE'S HAD IN
THE FIRST TWO YEARS.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO HAVE A LOT
MORE OVER THE NEXT SIX.
>> WILL THERE BE OTHER PEOPLE
THOUGH THAT WILL TRANSITION OUT?
>> EVERY ADMINISTRATION HAS
TURNOVER PARTICULARLY AFTER THE
MIDTERMS.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE
STAMINA THE PRESIDENT DOES.
I OFTEN SAY, I DON'T KNOW HOW
HE'S NOT TIRED BECAUSE THE REST
OF US CERTAINLY ARE.
AND THAT'S NOT NEW FOR ANY
ADMINISTRATION THAT YOU'LL HAVE
SOME PEOPLE THAT WILL CHANGE
OVER.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, THE
PRESIDENT'S GOT AN INCREDIBLY
DEDICATED TEAM THAT WANTS TO
CONTINUE TO SEE THE COUNTRY MOVE
FORWARD AND WE WANT TO SEE YOU
THE UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> IF YOU ARE GOING TO DO IT,